[Musique]
je
bienvenue dans votre magazine mode
d'emploi des voitures des pneus des
moteurs vous l'avez compris cette
semaine nous parlons automobile est là
et plus précisément en conception design
recherche et développement le futur
c'est déjà maintenant et c'est tout de
suite après votre sommaire aujourd'hui
je vous donne rendez-vous à l'estaca de
saint quentin en yvelines a ici on forme
les ingénieurs les plus pointues en
technique et en construction automobile
et là vous verrez comment naissent les
projets les plus fous
puis nous irons à maurepas où la société
style en design conçoit les prototypes
de demain implanté stratégiquement au
coeur de toutes les entreprises
automobiles
nous verrons comment elle réinvente le
futur aux premiers tâtonnements des
équipes mécaniques ont succédé des
réalisations innovantes d'ingénieurs
spécialisés petit retour en arrière sur
ces fabuleuse invention la conception
automobile remonte aux années 2000
époque à laquelle la vicieuse pratique
devient un engin prouesse technologique
conçu avec des méthodes d'une grande
précision et d'une grande maîtrise
on parle alors de voitures 100%
électriques ou hybrides de véhicules
énergétique de technologies améliorant
toujours plus le confort et la sécurité
du conducteur sur versailles l'institut
de recherche d'aidés comme est une
référence dans l'automobile autonome
entre caméra embarquée et voitures ultra
connectés les concessionnaires s'adapte
aux nouvelles tendances du 21e siècle et
des concessionnaires se forment de plus
en plus aux techniques de demain avec
pas moins de 150 entreprises automobiles
les yvelines et le premier département
de france dans le secteur automobile
avec la présence sur le territoire des
deux plus gros centre de recherche de
développement de france le technocentre
renault et le centre technique de psa
peugeot citroën
ce sont en tout plus de 45 mille
salariés qui travaillent dans les
départements l'estaca école supérieure
des techniques aéronautiques et de
construction automobile
on a tout dit ici on prépare les
étudiants à devenir des développeurs de
recherche
les ingénieurs aux technologies en mode
compétition automobile à mettez votre
ceinture et accrochez-vous c'est parti
pour un tour de circuit d'information
et comme d'ingénieurs sur cinq ans les
stars qui accueille deux mille étudiants
chaque année et propose quatre filières
auquel tous les étudiants sont initiés
la première année on fait une initiation
à l'automobile la filière spatiale à
l'aéronautique et au transport guidé et
dès la deuxième année on spécialisés les
étudiants dans une filière dont une
première partie sur tout ce qui est
technologie de l'automobile
et puis moins jusqu'à la cinquième année
se spécialise sur le produit automobile
que ce soit en termes de produits mais
également en termes de soft soit
embarquée et donc du coup ils ont une
sorte de l'estaca en étant spécialisé
dans une filière ils ont plusieurs choix
de métier le premier c'est
essentiellement en recherche et
développement
donc on travaillait sur le produit soit
sur tout ce qui est ce qu'on appelle les
daces tout ce qui est pour le véhicule
autonome détection de manger ou pour
garer votre véhicule automatiquement ça
s'appelle el adha ce serait on travaille
sur du conseil et d'étude soit dans un
an de la production dans les usines
soient dans d'autres secteurs comme du
marketing du commercial avec des
salaires plutôt attractif en début de
carrière
aujourd'hui en moyenne c'est après
trente mille euros par an sachant que
c'est une moyenne puisque on a quand
même là pour cent des étudiants qui
partent à l'international donc cela pas
plus important et puis il ya une
différence entre travail et provinces
mais les étudiants quand il sent de
l'escap australie sur tous types de
véhicules
ce soit du poids lourd du bus de
l'automobile évidemment vélo moto car
véhicules de compétition on a quand même
beaucoup d'étudiantes qui a su
passionner qu'on est une option sport
automobile en quatrième année
ils peuvent aller dans les écuries à et
chez les constructeurs de formule 1 par
exemple beaucoup de projets d'étudiants
sont encadrés par des industriels et
dans les trois mois après leur sortie de
l'école
94 % des étudiants trouvent un emploi
les industriels comptent y donne des
projets il détecte aussi des talents
dans les équipes projets vous pouvez
après les prendre en stage et après les
embauches et 70 % des enseignants de
l'estaca viennent du monde de
l'industrie et pour certains ce sont des
anciens diplômés de l'école comme
thierry thévenin ingénieur au groupe
renault et qui intervient à l'estaca
depuis huit ans
qui des bases techniques jeunes à
l'école mais c'était assez longtemps
c'est ensuite qu'ils beaucoup
d'expérience au sein pendant mon
parcours professionnel et maintenant je
veux restituer ce hameau étudiants c'est
à dire leur partage et du concret pour
aller en complément de des bases de
théorique technique pour l'heure qu'on
leur enseigne ici donc l'estaca en ce
moment je dispense des cours ou
quatrième année des cours de technique
automobile en suspension et en essieux
avant et arrière donc des techniques de
la voiture
le tourisme courante ou d'applications
compétition et ce genre de
l'enseignement se destine en particulier
vers les ingénieurs bureau d'études qui
ai eu mes dons conçoivent ce genre de
système et ce qu'apporte quelqu'un ici
l'industrie comme moi c'est justement
pouvoir donner beaucoup d'exemples de
pratiques de concret et le concret à
l'estaca il y en a à travers les trente
associations présentes au sein de
l'école et qui laisse aux étudiants
libre cours à leur imagination ici
naissent des projets innovants étudié
pour s'adapter aux nouvelles mobilités
et qui permettent aux étudiants de
pratiquer l'association est née en 2010
avec cinq élèves ingénieurs qui voit là
voulaient participer à la compétition
la formula student c'est le but de
l'estaca formule latine
je suis actuellement aussi au pôle
châssis donc cette année j'ai et v a
réalisé la nouvelle monocoque en fibre
de carbone de la nouvelle voiture
on va pouvoir en fait mettre en place
qu'on apprend en cours les différentes
technologies ou système que l'on peut
apprendre à maîtriser en cours à l'aide
de formules par exemple mais on va
pouvoir les implémenter faire le calcul
adapter le système pour le véhicule afin
qu'ils se comportent de la façon la plus
optimale possible lorsque l'on utilise
ce qu'on voit en cours on peut le mettre
en application
ça permet d'avoir une base en gros de ce
que l'on réalisera plus tard au niveau
du métier d'ingénieur
donc moi je suis au niveau des barres
antiroulis donc moi ce que j'aime dans
ce pôle donc c'est celui qu'on appelle
liaisons au sol c'est que c'est celui
qui est plutôt lié aux
aux pilotes c'est tout ce qui va être
réglage dynamique du véhicule
alors moi j'aimerais plutôt travailler
dans la compétition donc tout ce qui est
ingénieur performance par exemple mois
plus tard je me destine à travailler
dans le moteur vu que je suis à la
partie paul moteur c'est moi qui gère
aussi les essais sur circuit
du coup c'est intéressant de pouvoir
voir puisque l'interaction qui a entre
le moteur et et passage de puissance aux
roues arrière lorsqu'un projet super
intéressant qui va nous permettre
du coup de m'améliorer pour pouvoir
avoir un poste dans l'ingénierie dans
l'ombre dans les moteurs pourquoi pas de
compétition je suis dans le pô le groupe
motopropulseur de le ft dans
particularité de faisceaux en steeple
faisceaux en fait sinon qu'on s'occupe
du tout le toutes les parties
électriques de la voiture c'était le
pôle qui était le plus c'est lié avec le
ce que moi je voulais faire plus tard ce
qu'est le système embarqué en fait
puisque l électronique de la voiture
l'ordinateur de bord etc
cela fait trois ans que je suis le
projet estaca formula team avec les
différentes équipes qui se succèdent
tous les ans moi je les aide à
structurer un petit peu leur démarche
c'est à dire développer des jalons
développer un cahier des charges et
savoir comment concevoir et puis ensuite
je réponds si à leurs questions
techniques qui sont nombreuses
c'est là je mets au jeu met à profit mon
expérience pour les aider
justement appliquer leurs théories un
cas pratique et que c'est compliqué
sachez également que guillon cours le
campus les services de l'automobile et
de la mobilité vous accueillera pour
vous former aux métiers de la filière
automobile du ceap et au diplôme
d'ingénieur
l'ouverture est prévue en septembre 2018
avec une porte ouverte en mars
restons dans l'univers de la technologie
automobile mais dans le design de cette
fois-ci vous allez découvrir comment les
professionnels de l'image se joue des
matières des formes et des couleurs pour
vous concocter la voiture de vos rêves
c'est ici et c'est parti si recherche
développement forme et la matrice d'une
voiture la société style un design a
bien compris que l' enveloppe est un
élément essentiel au succès d'une marque
les marques qui performent bien sont
celles qui ont un design automobile qui
plaît aux attentes de leurs
consommateurs
beaucoup de véhicules ont des
prestations techniques équivalentes et
c'est le design qui va faire le plus et
nos deux constructeurs français
ou alors on est nous on est très fier
d'y participer mais dans leur gamme
respective
le design autant extérieure
qu'intérieure des véhicules est très
très performant et plus au marché
véritable laboratoire d'idées l' agence
de design innovent créent et réinvente
les voitures de demain du prototype aux
véhicules réel
chaque projet est un défi pour toute
l'équipe à tous les stades de la
fabrication et le design intervient sur
tout le processus de développement de
design qui est matérialisée dès le début
par des sketchs jusqu'à des maquettes de
validation et sheila physique vous voyez
pas la différence avec un vrai véhicule
et qui sont la maquette finale avant le
lancement s'est doté des dernières
technologies de conception et de
réalisation
la société s'est entouré d'une équipe
très performante de 110 collaborateurs
on a tous une douzaine de designers une
trentaine de modeleur numérique qui
modélise en trois dimensions ce que les
designers ont créé des codeurs des
imageurs et des graphistes et ensuite
une petite moitié dans les ateliers où
là on à 6500 mètres carrés d'ateliers
qui nous permet de fabriquer de réaliser
à l'échelle à des concept cars ou des
maquettes de
de validation des jalons on est très
très peu à avoir l'intégralité de tous
ces métiers rassembler sur un seul site
de nombreuses innovations qui sortent
tout droit de la tête des designers
alors la compétence des designers est
essentiel l'animation vous mettez dans
l'entreprise pour arriver à fédérer
toutes les équipes autour des projets
est aussi essentiel des designers dont
la qualité première est la créativité
faire la remise en question permanente
des choix qu'on fait c'est bien les
boules choix qu'ont fait penser à la
fois dans le détail de manière globale
après c'est l'engagement la passion on
travaille beaucoup avec nos tripes
soucis avec ma tête mais c'est surtout
nos tripes le coeur qui nous fait faire
des choses donc fait très engagé il faut
être passionné
une passion associé à un oeil artistique
et technique le quartier ticket est
important que ce qui nous permet d'avoir
une vision nous permet de décrire des
histoires qui sont belles et qui vont
apporter de la valeur à nos projets ou
aux produits qu'on est en train de
développer et la valeur technique elle
est essentielle parce que c'est ce qui
nous permettra de le rendre réel un
métier où les tensions sont nombreuses à
toutes les phases du projet les phases
de démarrage sont importants puisque
elle permet de comprendre parce que
attend notre client et on n'est pas dans
son intimité
donc on doit vite comprendre qu'est-ce
qu'il attend pourquoi il fait appel à
nous ce qui nous permet en fait de
choisir une stratégie de réponse c'est
que du subjectif et donc il faut amener
les gens à comprendre sur nous ce qu'on
veut faire c'est plutôt un état
permanent de penser et qui nous amène à
un moment une maturité est donc cette
maturité faut qu'il faut qu'on arrive à
prendre nos clients par la main pour les
accompagner là dedans dans un secteur où
la concurrence est rude
il faut également savoir se dit
aussi par la pensée la réalisation et
l'innovation naturellement les designers
vont aller chercher de la tendance
sociétale couleurs matières forme
conceptuelle et on utilise ça aussi
puisqu'on travaille donc plusieurs
domaines différents et donc on va
pouvoir ramener des concepts ramener des
idées d'autres domaines d'autres
technologies aussi les ramener dans le
domaine de l'automobile et donc tous ces
aspects là ça me permet d'être tous les
jours de se remettre en question de
savoir si on va dans le sens de proposer
des choses nouvelles
je faisais différenciante de mata se
déclarent de plus en plus vers le
digital et aux perspectives si les
courbes et la carrosserie vous ont plu
alors peut-être qu'un designer ou un
concepteur sommeille en vous dans ce cas
je vous invite à retrouver toutes les
informations pour accéder à ces
professions passion à la cité des
métiers de saint quentin en yvelines
sachez également qu'il vous sera
possible de découvrir d'autres métiers
tels que le soins et la rééducation
grâce à un zoom métiers organisé le 15
juin de 9h30 à 11h rendez vous à la cité
des métiers pour rencontrer deux
établissements qui recrutent dans ce
secteur et pour ceux et celles qui
souhaiteraient connaître les dispositifs
pour étudier ou travailler à l'étranger
un professionnel vous accueillera la
maison de l'europe des yvelines le 22
juin de 14h à 17h enfin n'oubliez pas
les programmes personnalisés objectif
emploi de l'école de la deuxième chance
en yvelines
si vous avez entre 18 et 25 ans le de
ses soixante dix huit vous donne la
possibilité de suivre une formation
gratuite pour accéder à un emploi
les prochaines missions auront lieu le
12 juin et le 11 septembre
quant à nous on se retrouve
prochainement pour un nouveau mode
d'emploi mais en attendant prenez soin
de vous
[Musique]
à